and tonight the fight to save women's
sports continues now yesterday Riley
Gaines and other activists they were
accosted and allegedly spat on by trans
activists following a ceremonial signing
for a bill protecting women's sports in
the state of Texas here's a small sample
of the harassment they were facing take
a look
[Music]
also Riley Gaines recently appeared on
Bill Maher's Club random where she was
half some well I guess interesting
questions about her experience in a
shared locker room with Leah Thomas take
a look
beat you in the locker room with a big
there we go in that case
how big is her
well I've seen her right we all did how
big is it I mean what kind of is it
describe let's see
um well I don't want to see it well I
just wanted to hear it well if I had to
see it you have to hear it first of all
this is a six foot four man
all right continuing your fight to
protect women's sports Riley is now
launching the Riley Gaines Center at the
Leadership Institute where she will
serve as director she's also the host of
the outkick podcast gains for girls
Riley Gaines joins us now now I do have
some good news I will not be following
up on Bill Maher's line of questioning
although to be honest I mean the part
that I didn't know is that you're all
naked in the same
locker room I didn't know that part I
don't know how I missed it but I didn't
know
that had to be what did you think
happened in the locker room
especially
sorry I didn't know especially in the
sport of swimming where you're
undressing from your clothes to your
suit and then from your suit into your
racing suit and then back from your
racing suit into your other suit and
then I mean you're undressing in that
locker room
um at least teammates did it 18 times
per week they undressed in front of him
so I mean that's sexual harassment at
its best
you know what that really is a great
Point by the way that really is and and
on so many different levels and
um
you know what I think America needs to
hear that by the way and I thought you
handled Bill Maher's tough and he's
funny and you know I get his line of
questioning but it's revealing in the
sense that's really not fair and this
whole issue this was the save women's
sports act that you were there for the
signing of and that's what this really
comes down to here because if you've got
to allow
mediocre uh biological men to compete
against women the physical differences
are deep and profound and it's not fair
they want to create a separate trans
category how about it but leave women's
sports alone good for you
absolutely the women's sporting category
is not a failed retirement plan for male
athletes that's not what it is
we as women of course we are different
than men it's not to say we're inferior
but we're different we have different
physical ceilings and it's we're unique
in our own ways therefore of course men
should not be competing against women or
changing in her locker rooms under any
circumstance
I love your podcast titled gains for
girls and you also said with Bill Maher
that hey you know what I'm not going to
use the promo pronouns you said mail
this is a man in the locker room this is
you you refuse to go along and play the
pronoun game what's the reaction that
you get to holding that position
at first it took me a while to get to
this point right I felt like I had to be
respectful I felt like I had to be kind
but that's what they want you to think
they want you to think it's kind to use
the pronouns and to adhere to these lies
but that's not kind that's the exact
opposite of kind to lie to affirm any
delusion is that's not compassionate
that's not kind that's not inclusive or
tolerant or accepting that's lying and
lying is not beneficial for anyone and
so it took me a while to come to terms
with how I honestly felt and to speak
the truth and that truth is that Leah
Thomas is a male anyone who has gone
through male puberty has Y chromosomes
born as a male is a male regardless of
how they identify
tell me about the the Riley Gaines
Center at the Leadership Institute which
you're now starting
um and listen your voice has been very
powerful in this entire debate
um Caitlyn Jenner's been on this program
agrees completely with you well what
were the uh testosterone levels at
puberty because that's when it matters
not at the age of 21 or 20 or 23 or
whatever the H happens to be uh is and
seemed to be full in full agreement when
I interviewed her the question I asked
tell me about The Institute you're
sorting or the Riley Gaines Center
the Riley Gaines Center is something
that I wish I had when I began to speak
up and when I faced the humiliation of
the locker room and giving up our
trophies for a photo op the mission is
to empower and train and provide
resources to students athletes parents
coaches medical professionals other
allies who want to help in the fight to
defend women defend freedom of speech
actually too and women's sports of
course and so it will be a training
program we'll be doing
school board training putting
conservative speakers on college
campuses which I think is really
important to engage younger people and
mobilize them
well you do you and you got you were
being spit at yesterday did they did you
get spit on or were they just trying
no there were people spitting on the
protesters spitting on us there were
police reports fire filed there were
arrests that were made you can see in
these videos that they're dumping water
on the legislators I mean it's crazy but
it's actually encouraging really because
it shows you they have to resort to
violence they have to resort to
name-calling and these Petty attacks to
dissuade from our argument because they
don't have truth they don't have common
sense they don't have logic or reasoning
on their side they have name calling and
you don't waste ammunition on targets
that you don't want to hit we're right
over the Target on this uh Riley you got
a lot of Courage I give you a lot of
credit for what you're doing and uh
we're going to be following this very
closely thanks for being with us again
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else